what's happening you savages
thank you very much for coming out ahead
on wednesday night i know y'all guys are
doing a lot of [__] tonight you know you
had plans
like to sit on the 134 for another
[__] hour
it was bumper to bumper thank god i
don't give a [__] about the hov lane
i got right in that [__] solo
like john lennon solo i said [__] it 90
i don't give a [__] about the ticket
i gotta go up to the ice house and see
some savages tonight
but uh you know as is it's testicle
testaments you know where uh
you find out how you got your balls this
is what it's about we tell a couple
stories
and you go home and you think about and
you twit me tomorrow i don't give a [__]
what you do you know what i'm saying
but it's weird because most of the
testicles testaments i talk about have
to do with crime or drugs or whatever
and i got a couple people tweeting me
asking me about comedy
you know how i got into comedy and what
had happened and uh
it's funny because a couple years ago i
got a movie called the longest yard
right and
when i got it i was [__] in shock i
mean
i'm a piece of [__] and here i am in
this table read and i'm sitting next to
burt reynolds
and i'm sitting across from tracy morgan
and chris rock and all these [__]
people and i'm sitting there going
these [__] knew
that 15 years ago i was mugging hookers
and lighting their wigs on fire
you know if these [__] knew
that you know
i'm a little [__] up you know you know
the only other criminal in the room was
romanovsky right he was on probation
for beating some guy up with a helmet
and [__] right and he couldn't even sit
next to me with two felons in the room
he had to sit on the other side
so on the other side [__]
balanced this out
and i'm sitting there with the guy from
uh 48 hours luther
and he was in warriors you know warriors
come out to play and i'm looking at this
guy and i'm going i grew up
watching this [__] and here i am sitting
next to these [__] and i'm like
i wouldn't even get in my car because i
thought i was going to get into a car
accident
like when i got the longest yard like
the four or five days before that i
would look at buildings
because i thought a building was gonna
fall on my [__] head
because after what i had done in my life
to be on a [__] set of this movie and
i remember them flying down to
when i got that movie i had 13
i had a couple cigarettes and i had like
a 10
bag of weed and that's what i went down
to new mexico with
and they flew me down the plane like i
thought i was going to lax no no
no we got a private plane i remember
getting to the table read the first day
and adam sandler was outside with
flip-flops on they carried my luggage
and i'm like oh my [__] god
these [__] have no idea you
know they have no idea
he's like how are you how you feeling he
carried my luggage come on daddy we
gotta get upstairs i'm like oh
this [__] and i got no money and
i fly
down there and i get to the hotel room
and i don't even have a credit card to
put down the deposit
right i don't have a [__] credit card
i like to put the deposit
like i was like what am i gonna do and i
get there and i'm like they're like joey
yeah they give me this package
and i take it up to my room right and i
open the [__] pack and there's an
envelope with 800
cash in there and and there was car keys
like [__] car keys and i look and
it's a rental thing from like alamo
and they rented this like a [__] suv
i didn't have a driver's license
[Laughter]
i'm like didn't even ask me to see it
like usually people can we see a
driver's license i don't have a [__]
driver's license
i had one but i didn't have it with me
you know what i'm saying like i had a
license in colorado i had one in new
jersey
i had one in seattle but i didn't have
any of them on me at the time you know
what i'm saying
because [__] it why carry a license here
if i do something they'll find it [__]
it i didn't even carry a license in
those days
who is he i don't know i don't even know
who the [__] i am dog
you know so i didn't know what the [__]
was going on so
and then i remember the first day of
shooting like guys
you have no idea i was a criminal
and here i am with chris rock and adam
sandler they got cameras in my face
but all these guys were comics you know
and i was scared [__] because you're
always scared [__] i'm always i'm a
[__] when it comes to that stuff i was
petrified and i remember them having to
do the first scene which is the tree out
that day and they're all watching and
when i finished the scene like before
the scene people
were stood away from me like i had a
cold or had hiv
but after the scene they started talking
to me like what's up dog what the [__]
you been
done i'm like something happened you
know and i didn't know when i did the
movie the movie came out whatever and i
went into
a funk and but just getting that movie
at that time was [__] huge for me
like it had blown me the [__] away
because all the parts i was getting were
one day
two days a day and a half [__] like that
i was never getting like a big [__]
movie so this was like used for me
and throughout the whole shooting like
the first six weeks i didn't even do
coke
i was i was so hooked on coke at the
time i did a gram a night and
those first six weeks i didn't even do
coke because my head would blow up
i would just sit in the room and smoke
pie and write and
think about where the [__] you know and
it's funny because
you always want to do something when
you're a kid you see a fireman you're
like [__] i'm going to be a fireman
you know you then you watch a a show and
you want to be that thing i want to jump
off helicopters you know
so your whole life you're thinking about
[__] when i get older i'm gonna jump off
helicopters
but then you get to high school and you
smoke pot and you eat some girls [__]
and you fail you got a d
and [__] don't work out so the rest of
the time you're like i want to be a
helicopter pilot
and you get a day job but we just don't
know how to [__] pursue it like
that's the biggest thing like i always
do look i'm from cuba
first time i've seen charles bronson the
velocity papers i i i was like that's
what i want to do
i want to be in [__] movies how do
you get movies and i would ask people i
want to be in a movie
talk that would say my sister works on
films what does she do she sweeps
[__] talk to her dog
i'm ready dawg you know [__] the nero i
can [__] his [__] up dog
you know i didn't know nothing and i met
a guy in boulder that was a camera guy
and i would always torture him when i
was going to college dog you got to put
me in the movies like what do you do
what the [__] you mean what do i do i do
it all and he's like what
will you do you know but it's weird how
uh when i was a little kid like i came
from cuba and i learned how to speak
english by watching comedy television
all these [__] people get the
earphone
and they give 60 dollars to suzanne
whatever to learn how to speak language
you don't need to do that [__]
all you need to do is put tv learn one
word at a time and then put the rest of
the [__]
together i knew chocolate i knew the
word chocolate that's the first word i
knew when i came from cuba
chocolate but i didn't know it was
chocolate i thought it was chocolate
late
so i always thought you had to eat
chocolate at night like [__] a dog i
don't eat chocolate at night dawg it's
chocolate late
so so the power of the language and like
dick van dyke i used to watch dick van
dyke every day
and i wasn't [__] laughing i was just
trying to learn english and then
through the laughter he taught me
[__] english you know like that's how
i learned it
but i had never known what stand-up
comedy was i watched television like the
rest of us
and one day right you're about 10 you're
playing with like a little [__] kid
that you're not supposed to be playing
with likes
this is a puerto rican kid right i don't
even remember what his name was guillo
or something he's dead now
but yeah we were like the same mage he
died i don't know he died of a heart
attack he had diabetes i don't [__]
know right
but he had like a cousin and his name
was dune buggy
right and he took me up to dune buggies
one day i'm like 10 or 11 he takes me up
to dune buggies
and we're listening to like the beatles
and [__] we think we're bad you know
like the beatles or the yellow submarine
and dune buggy was a heroin addict
right like and you guys have never seen
in the 70s in new york city there were
heroin addicts everywhere they fall
asleep
they just be talking to you awesome they
just
bro what happened i didn't know you know
it's [__] hysterical
it is hysterical if you've never seen it
you see people you know like
you like when you walk up to [__]
light and there's lights green and you
can't cross
i actually seen junkies fall asleep
waiting for the [__] day
like they fall on the [__] floor and
people just step over them it's new york
we don't give a [__] you know what i'm
saying so we go up there
and we're in there listening to the
beatles and dune buggy comes in and my
mother had a bar so i knew about drugs
but
heroin was [__] great he comes and
he's all [__] up what are you
[__] listening to
and he's cursing like what are your
little [__] listening tell me
what the fool's this [__] guy
he's like that's my cousin doom buggy
dog he's [__] up he's on drugs
so he sits down and he's like what the
[__] is his music
like this to be those [__] and he's
like nah nah nah take that [__] off i
want you to listen to this album
and he put this album called richard
pryor the nigger's crazy
and they put on the dracula meets wino
i don't know if you've heard it i don't
care if you've heard it
do you know when you see something
that's put you in a different level in
your life
like sometimes you're watching the
olympics and they get the gold medal and
it makes you get emotional or your tears
come in your eyes or something
we all have something you know we watch
[__] desperate housewives there's
something
that gets you emotional sometimes well
this was it listening to richard pryor
was mind-boggling here i was a cuban kid
i took me seven years to learn english
you know like just to get it together
and now this guy's in there talking
about [__] you and your mother
and where'd you get that dirt on the
back of your neck you're a filthy
[__] too
and i'm like what the [__] is this
and dune buggy's nodding by that time
i'm like dune buggers i stalk i'm trying
to listen to the album you know i'm
saying shut up
i was blown away and my first [__]
mission when i left there was [__] the
jackson five
[__] the osmonds i'm getting that
nigga's crazy album by richard pryor
you know i'm like this is too much this
is just too much all this language and
all this beauty
i was blown the [__] away and i went
home and in the old days guys
when you had a dirty album like that it
was a dirty album like now you got a cd
or a download on your ipod
but you have an album everybody had to
hear it so you had to put the richard
pryor album on
and then put like the beatles over it so
if your mother walked in the room you
could drop the beatles
so he's talking about suck my dick [__]
and all of a sudden you're like boom bam
help i need somebody help not just
anybody help
so your mom don't know what just
happened i don't know ma i don't know
you know i just need someone my you know
i'm saying help help
[__] i need somebody
so you know that was the scam then when
she left the room she [__] it up dog
finds us
then after that after the nigga's crazy
came up with bicentennial [__]
and was it something i said so i had
gotten all these kids in my neighborhood
you know because my mother had the bar
in the afternoon so we would go to my
house
put the album on and [__] close the
door and at that time we didn't even
smoke pot yet
i wasn't even smoking pot yet we would
do this [__] straight like a soldier
like a soldier in iraq straight in that
[__] little huddle there
six guys sitting around giggling at the
bad words and what he was saying
and then i watched it on television by
that time you know you [__] seen
comedians i seen richard pryor
and george carlin and i knew it was
there and that was it
like i just knew like i never said to
myself i want to do stand-up comedy
i just knew that option was there [__]
that's a weird thing to do and that's it
i just moved on it's like you girls see
prostitution what are you you see porno
you see a girl taking in the ass you're
like i do that once a week i could do
that you know what i'm saying
i'm not gonna do that but if things got
bad and i lost my job i could do that
same thing you know and that's how it
starts with comedy because the comedy it
pisses tests us
like sometimes you watch comedian on tv
and you're like i'm funny in that dude
[__] that punk you know i could do this
and that's one inspiration from it but i
never even thought about comedy i wanted
to be a [__] movie star
i didn't want to be a movie star i just
want to kill people on stage you know
what i'm saying
like i just want to kill people in the
movies and get in my car and going to
the sunset
i didn't want to ride a horse or make
out with people or do no no no no no no
no
i always wanted to be a bad guy in the
movies once i seen velocity papers or
charles bronson
i knew that was my [__] goal and that
was it that was it
my mother passed away i got into crime
you know
whatever but before all that [__]
started
like people always said to me when did
you really start standing up calm and i
always thought
it was 91 but when i was a freshman in
high school
i used to play basketball i played
basketball every year but
freshman year especially we used to take
the bus from 80th street
to [__] 29th street on the way home
and at
605 the bus driver would open that door
and 15
savages would get on that door we were
savages you understand me i mean
we would torture people on the bus it
was like a charles bronson movie like
death wish when the guys get on the bus
and
take people's hats off and put snots on
them that was uh
and that's where we learned how to [__]
with junkies because there was always a
junkie on that [__] bus
going to jersey city coming back from
the
methadone center because after they get
off heroin they drink methadone which is
even [__] worse that puts you to
sleep and you drool
but the best was that was our job to
[__] around with the heroin people so
they'd be
one particular had their [__] daily
news open and he's sitting there and the
bus is moving right
and he's passed the [__] out passed out
and his mouth is open he's got a drool
spit a string
connected from his lip to the newspaper
and it's a little puddle of drool like
three or four inches of drool right
and he's just sitting there all [__]
up and you know i
sat next to him and i fought it really
[__] bad right
that was part of the game we were
torture [__] junkies right
toy to the junkie that was it and that
was on the way up on the way down it was
different you tortured housewives and
[__] like that
but on the way up and they would just be
coming from their methadone [__] and
they'd be all [__] up
so the next night i sat next to this
[__] and i farted good one of
those morning farts
when you're 14 you ate like a box of
[__] cereal
and milk and bananas you know how it
gets when you
and you don't want to [__] so you take
it with you to school
it's in your ass so i blasted one of
those in the morning like 8 15
[__] coming at you
and this [__] was like this
right
and also he went
and he wiped his face and he goes what
the [__] is wrong with you little
[__]
he goes bothering me when i'm trying to
read the [__] paper
reed you've been passed out for 20
minutes
look at you little [__]
we used to see some [__] up [__] on
that bus dog [__] up [__] on that bus
and then we had to pass this area called
lucci 64th street field and these were
the savages of my hometown
these kids didn't even have kids they
killed their parents like they didn't
have parents like they had all killed
their kids
lincoln school we had nine grammar
schools in north bergen but lincoln
school
was where the kids went to basketball
games and chains with a guy whipping
them and [__] they were
they were half [__] but they were
criminals and they put them all together
i swear to god
the third floor was for momos and the
criminals on the bottom floor would
throw him off the [__] roof and [__]
lincoln school and the principal had one
of those eagle eyes that went up and
said
what is the meaning of this [__] right
he had one of those things
what is the meaning of this
[Laughter]
so this was the roughest
[__] italian irish [__] you
ever met in your life
dirty white [__] sons of
anarchy [__] type right
so one day we on this bus and it just
snowed in new york like 92 [__]
inches of snow
now when it snows 92 inches of snow you
[__] drive with your windows closed
especially north bergen because we would
set up behind cars and get snowballs and
dip them in [__] water
and throw those things that you're
[__] lethal type [__] in the winter
tremendous
so we're on this bus we got on the bus
and the windows are open
in the middle because it was hot in the
daytime after the snow it gets hot the
next day the sun's out melting [__]
but that [__] snow that melting snow
you take that water and an ice ball
becomes a [__]
boulder of death it just
so this guy gets on with two of his
cousins and he's italian i don't know if
he's gay and he's speaking italian
or mama mia and all they say right so
i'll never [__] forget this i could
be 80
and i see him you know when you see
something happening is the best
like sometimes you see like an old lady
cross and you see a guy robbing the red
light and you're like
i'm watching this [__] this this is
going down right in front of me and you
see it
you see it evolving like you see her and
you get the hardest [__] getting hit
i'm gonna watch this [__]
so they're walking on the bus and we
from north bergen it's the hilliest
city in the country behind san francisco
so when you get on the bus you're always
like trying to climb up in the seats
it's going downhill and this
[__] is going 80. he gets on the
bus
we're in the back like little criminals
and i see him but in the middle somebody
had left the windows open
and right there i know that's what these
kids on 64th street look for
they got a guy like with a walkie-talkie
a bus coming with windows open [__]
bombard right so i see the windows up
and he's all happy it's sunny out he's
got his italian white hat on
mamma mia and all this [__] and he
[__] he puts his cousins
on this two side this seat here and he
sits alone right here and the windows
wide the [__] open
and me at that time i was like a half a
wee blow like i was only a boy scout for
like three or four days
and i could have stopped them as a boy
scout you're supposed to be excuse me
sir close the windows there's some
savages in the [__] thing
remember that scene apocalypse now when
i got the boat and people start throwing
spears and [__] no no
within minutes i said this to myself i
go this [__] is about to get
bombarded
with that window open and sure enough
you just hurt
and they were coming from both
directions and the cousins like give us
all keep us all because
get fired and this [__] is
looking around and he looks out the
window
and you hear it you just hear it
and it just hits this [__] right
and he get you
like that type of [__] right
and we're in the back howling at this
[__] point
he gets on the floor the [__]
snowball hits some thread on
like a chocolate dull punch he hits the
floor he gets up bleeding profusely i
never forget he goes
stop at the bus
stop any buzz
i could be 80 and i'm going to be
giggling about that someday
and my deathbed stupid buzz
so that was where i started my comedy
career right there without knowing
we would get on there first thing we do
is start singing the odd couple theme
the whole [__] back of the bus and i
do the whole verbiage you know oscar
madison's wife threw him out
requesting that he never returned can
two divorced men
share an apartment and then we'd do
scenes from the honeymooners
saturday night live and then i just go
up there and [__]
get on one of the chairs i'd be holding
on and i'd be just cracking jokes
goofing on the people on the bus
when we got off that bus drive be so
[__] pissed off he'd be furious like
you little [__]
you're never taking my bus again you
little [__] [__] you mr bus driver
[__]
and he would the next night he just fly
past us [__] you [__]
[__]
so that's why really kind not knowing it
like i'm not even [__] knowing it
and then people would say you know what
bro you're funny but i come from a town
in jersey where
everybody's [__] funny then my mother
died right
and when you're in high school when
you're a kid your mom dies or anytime
your mom dies when you're 15 your mom
dies
first year you're going through a lot of
[__] anybody dies and my mother
died and i had these friends that didn't
even let me think about being sad they
were so funny
till today i talked to this guy roger
three times a week because he's the
funniest person
you know like when uh you watch the news
and some white guy comes out greetings
you know welcome to ktla news uh a man
just robbed the bank and
hit the lady on the head details coming
at 11. then they asked like the black
guy what happened [__]
this [__] tried to be a hero
[__] hitler with a cash register
in the head
that was roger he'd tell you and he
always had like an inner text
his inner text was hysterical he would
whisper so
we're driving we'd see like three
[__] crazy people go look at these
[__] under his breath and you
would giggle
and i i always thought about how it made
me feel
like what i was going through when i get
home at night at midnight of an hour and
i'd start getting depressed
but while i was with these guys i
laughed my [__] ass off
but again i never thought about it
so now i'm on north bergen i'm a
full-time [__] criminal full-time
drugs kidnapping hookers wigs i'm going
for it right [__] it
i got felonies and jersey the whole
[__] thing i moved to colorado
and i got arrested and i i get sent to
prison you know and
prison is weird because you could go to
prison and not get something out of it
and i didn't know i was going to get
something out of it i just thought i was
going to boys camp for a couple weeks
smoke some pot do some drugs in there
wasn't like that but it kind of was
but it kind of was do you follow me so
when i get to my destination
i would talk to people and i'm cuban so
i could talk to black people mexicans
that don't matter to me i don't give a
[__] i ain't
i'm racially insensitive but i ain't
racist you're following me
two big [__] differences you know and
i let people know and they're like [__]
at least you're real
you know i talk how people talk behind
closed [__] doors
all right that's how they talk you know
they don't they're gonna say some
[__] nice hispanic man cut me off in
the 405
they're gonna say no some [__]
[__] [__] cut me the [__] off
on a 405.
okay so why beat around the bush i know
we try to be christians and republicans
but
[__] that [__] at the end of the day
right when you get to heaven god's gonna
say you faked it all those [__] years
all right [__] be honest with
yourself get rid of that bmw you're
puerto rican
get it together so
uh it was funny because this italian
dude came up to me and he's like dog
i see how you talk to people and for
some reason they like you you make them
laugh
he goes i'm selling these football
tickets like illegal football tickets
and i can't do well with the minorities
and i can't do well with the white
people
can you help me and i'll be your partner
i ain't going to help you i'll partner
with you we'll make 50 50.
and this guy went from selling one card
a week for monday football
i was selling everything ping pong i was
selling everything china and we didn't
have to have the internet in prison
i was just making up tennis tournaments
and [__] listen
and and i've seen it he would say to me
dog you get along with people
then they made me in charge of the
kitchen right i
never cooked the [__] thing in my
life when i get to prison the guy's like
you look like a cook [__] his
name is
yarborough big black [__] from
mississippi six foot eight big
[__]
where you from cuba oh you [__]
and he was just torturing me every day
you [__] cabanos are bad people
look what you're doing you let your
prisons out 130 000 criminals and all
this are you one of those [__]
so the first day he made me a baker
right and he made me told me to make
cinnamon buns i never made cinnamon buns
so i made these cinnamon buns and they
[__] blew up the oven they were this
big they came out
i made them like this big but when they
came out they were this [__] biggest
i get fired i thought you were cuban i
thought you could cook
i can't cook said i'm gonna make you the
stock clerk driver
so the stock like you're in charge of
this area and i would have the keys and
i would i could [__] uh hold
weed for people on steroids and charge
them rent it was a great [__] scam
but it it was [__] crazy like i i had
all these friends
and usually in prison people stand among
themselves so the whites but i
[__] bounced around i got one with
everybody i went to the library
and i would check the meet listen i'm a
[__] picky [__] eater
you'll never see me at taco bell or
mcdonald's since i was a kid my mother
didn't let me eat fast food
when he came from cuba i wasn't about
the kentucky fried chicken when i went
to miami to see my cousins [__] yeah
we tore up that [__] colonel but in
new york in front of my mom she's like
[__] no we gotta eat the santeria
chickens we can't eat that [__] you know
what i'm saying
so i never really uh dabbled in any of
that [__] you know
so i hate [__] cheap food so the
invics would come in
and i would hide behind like a curtain
and they'd all look at me like
what's good to eat and i would yell
don't do it
right whenever they get like the
macaroni and cheese if it was shitty
cheese
like welfare cheese don't do it
constipation coming constipation coming
constipation alert
i would say [__] like that and mr yarber
would say what the [__] you saying back
there behind that curtain boy
why aren't these [__] eating
the [__] on shingles [__] on shingles is
what they eat three times a [__] week
it's cream meat over bread it's [__]
gross
i don't know who invented it i'm gonna
look it up tonight on wikipedia i'm
happy
you [__] remind him i'm gonna
look that [__] up and bomb his
whole family that [__]
because when you go to prison you eat
that [__] three times a week
cream which they call it [__] on
shingles and it's [__] meat with
[__] milk
over bread it's [__] horrible you
understand me
and the meat is like salami burnt
and they chop it up and they mix like a
finger in there and then they put it all
together oh
and i would yell don't do it
but then at the end of the night in the
kitchen they would ask me a question
and i would [__] go off like i would
just go off on everybody [__] what the
[__] did you do all day [__] you
didn't do [__]
you were sitting back there talking to
your girlfriend and i would just go off
so on thursday nights they used to have
movie night and they had a shitty
projector
so they put the project on and 10
minutes into the movie boom the
projector would break and they have to
call the [__] guy
he was like hannibal like they come out
with like fake teeth and [__] but he's
the only one who knew how to fix the
projector and [__] they
they would give him like a weapon and he
would have to sharpen it it was [__]
it was a 35 minute process
so they would say where's the cuban go
up there and crack some jokes
really and they go yeah go up there and
crack some juice just talk about the
prison
and i would go up there and just lay it
into the guy it's like it was like death
chance
i go look at this black [__]
over here on the phone eight hours a day
with his chicks with black people on the
phone all day
with their girlfriends you gotta sign up
for the phone they're on their own dog
i'll give you a homie for your phone
they'll give you a dollar to buy your
[__] 20 minutes it was crazy so i
would talk about how the black guys were
always on the phone they would always be
yelling that night
you know just on a goof on the white
people i goof on the mexicans the cubans
the whole thing and i didn't even know
what i was doing
i was just going up there and [__]
around and then i used to go to the
library in the afternoons because the
dude in the library was very
different he was like duncan trussell
right he was very intellect he had
glasses he the only guy who had glasses
in jail
he recited [__] nietzsche and i asked
him what you did one day and he goes i
killed my wife and her boyfriend [__] it
and i'm like this is a bad [__]
right here
but he's reciting nietzsche and he knew
things i had never even heard about and
he liked me and i liked him in fact we
got acid one night and tripped together
and i told him to break down how he
killed his wife or his [__] classic
dog
he broke it down how he stabbed her and
she was begging and [__] [__] you [__]
and he pissed on both of them and he
called the cops himself
no this is a good story trust me and
when you're on acid you want to shoot
yourself you're like really
let me try it on myself you know this
[__] under the night one time he
just broke it down i killed him both dog
i went home i stabbed that [__] and i
stabbed him i was like god
damn i wish i had 3d glasses and [__]
right now
because 3d glass and the story he told
me was [__] phenomenal
i asked him we were scared for a week
because the only way they could test you
for acid
is to tap into your spine piss doesn't
test acid in prison
the only thing they test you for in piss
is called coke or h or heroin or
barbiturates or thc
but when you did acid and [__] it didn't
come up so for a week we were both
paranoid but he became my buddy i really
liked him and i trust him i had a couple
buddies in there
i had this black dude antoine aka
chickenhawk another guy stabbed somebody
he was in there for six years for
involuntary manslaughter
he told me the story how he stabbed the
guy i love all that [__]
when people tell you a good story that's
a good story you know what i'm saying
like how they stabbed somebody he went
upstairs and got the knife
and the grandmother he stabbed her and
he went downstairs that's [__]
interesting [__] right there right [__]
modern family i need that [__] oh [__]
yourself you know what i'm saying this
is
it's real this reality tv in your head
you know
so uh the guy the white dude in the
library was
really tight with me and one day i went
in and he gave me a notebook and the
notebook was really hard to get you
could either get loose paper but a black
notebook
and he goes i want you to write your
jokes in there you know and i go i don't
have no [__] jokes
and he goes listen what do you mean
you've got no jokes he goes when you go
up there during the week you don't say
no then i go no i don't write nothing
i just go up there and [__] around he's
like
and he took off his glasses he had like
tears in his eyes he's like listen
when you get out of here if you don't
try standing up comedy i'm gonna break
out of here and kill you he had like
another 90 years left
he's like i'm gonna break out of here
and kill you you do know that he goes i
want you to get out of here and
focus on he goes sometimes
in life you focus on weird [__] he told
me some stuff that was
just mind-boggling he said he told me to
he goes you ever think about how much
time you put into getting a grandma coke
or calling a girl he goes i want you to
put that same focus into comedy
he goes if you do this he goes dog i'm
going to read about you
and i was like you know
i would have laughed but he killed his
wife and the [__] boyfriend you know
i'm saying
you can't laugh when you have a guy like
that around you i just looked at him and
i shook his hand i said thank you for
the notebook and i went away and i
didn't really think about it then
something else happened
i had this counselor and he [__] was
racist
he was a white dude from the south but
he hated everybody
he hated everybody and i understood it i
didn't i wasn't mad at him
and i would meet with him once a week
and he'd ask me questions and i would
say to him dog when they took me in they
did a psychological
because when you go to prison they do
your physical but then they take you
into a room for three days and you have
to put [__] balls and [__] and
they ask you what this picture reminds
you of and you know and i always wanted
to know if i was crazy just so i knew
you know i'm like am i crazy though he's
like i can't tell you that
and i would ask him every day dog tell
me what's on the psychological tell me
what's on the [__] psychological
and he kind of hated me but i busted his
ball so much they started to like me you
know when somebody hates you
but you show them that much love after
[__] three or four months they start
to like you
and one day i call them outside i go
blue when the [__] are you gonna [__]
tell me what's on the psychological
because that was his name mr blue and he
goes listen bug [__]
he goes you know what's on that thing do
you really want to hear what's on that
thing [__] and i go yeah tell me
once and for all and when he told me
like that i got scared i'm like maybe i
don't want to hear what's on that
[__] thing
so he called me in his office and he
opened up the file and he went to a page
and he turned it around he goes [__]
read that right there
and it said that i would never get in
trouble again i would never recidivate
whatever the [__] big word they use
and at the end it said that i'm very
dangerous because if i wanted something
i could get it some wording like that
and i said what does that mean
i'm a [__] thief and he goes yeah in
a way he goes it means that if you
[__] want something
that i have for me to give it to you
because you're gonna take it from me
and i was blown away guys i was it was a
hole in my [__] heart
it confirmed everything that i thought
about myself that was a piece of [__]
you know i'm not gonna lie to you i
always thought until today i'm still in
the back of my mind
we're insecure bro and i had it and at
least you recognize it
and it fuels you you know it fuels you
and i went to that room for three days i
didn't crack no [__] jokes i didn't
go to movie night
i didn't do [__] because that's it i'm
doomed
and i seen him again he goes how you
doing bug [__] and i go not too good
since you told me that he goes
he goes you're a dumb [__] [__]
he goes you took it as a thief he goes
you didn't take it for what it said
it said that if you wanted to do
something in this world you could do it
and he walked away from me and i was
shattered i was like what the [__] is
this [__] talking about
that's it i get out of the [__]
prison
i go sell cars i start slinging coke
again you know me
whole habits die hard i'm in the halfway
house trying to be marlon brando
right and i didn't even think about
[__] comedy i had a girlfriend i got
her pregnant
so you know we had to have a [__] kid
i had to get married
never thought about it i got [__]
married guys for all the wrong reasons
sometimes in your life society you're
like i gotta get married and have a kid
and you
do it and you're like this ain't what i
[__] wanted and it happens all the
time people just don't have the balls to
say i'm [__] now
you know and then they start drinking
and they do drugs and then the rest is
[__] history it's just a bad [__]
cycle
well let me tell you something i i
thought i loved her until we were on the
plane to the honeymoon
and it happens i was like what the [__]
did i just do
you know because now she went from being
a girlfriend to becoming a wife and it
was complaining i couldn't handle it
i was on my own since i was [__] 12
basically now i got somebody over my
shoulder i couldn't [__] handle it
i was like there's no way like make sure
you do this [__] you i do what i do
i don't tell me nothing i already got in
my [__] head you know what i'm saying
so i got into a [__] depression guys
like people talk about depression
oh my god i can't wake up in the morning
[__] you i was there
i was there i was doomed in my heart i
was doomed guys and i'm sorry
uh people don't look at me wrong here i
was 20 [__] eight
27 26 married with a kid
my friends are in new york hanging out
at studio 54 getting that dick sucked
and here i am in colorado surrounded by
[__] republicans
no [__] food people running healthy
people blow like a [__] though
tons of drugs but here i am you know and
this is it
i'm going to be a [__] roofer from
monday to friday till i'm 60 [__]
five years old
guys i went [__] nuts i hated going
home i used to be a roofer and estimate
i would leave at six
i wouldn't get home till seven o'clock
at night i was miserable i used to
listen
i tried to become six different
religions in that time
i tried to become a buddhist on monday
nights i would walk around in circles
with a bunch of people with no shoes on
dirty [__] feet walking around
getting fungus
i did that for about two weeks [__] that
[__] right
then i went to the naropa institute i
was gonna become a philosopher
again a bunch of people don't take
showers with a trust fund i don't need
that [__]
telling me about what's really
crack-a-lacking meanwhile your dad's
sending you 40
000 a [__] month you know you're
riding a bicycle
you're not even taking showers because
you're ashamed that you don't have a
[__] job but you're playing this on
poor [__]
and you're [__] filthy rich i'm with
a room with those [__] momos
then i said oh no no no no i know what
my problem is
i didn't make my [__] confirmation
that's what it was
as a catholic i should have made my
confirmation that [__] 13.
i went to the church and i signed up at
sacred heart uh was the sacred heart
yeah it was like uh
saint tom oh the [__] knows who gives a
[__] it's a saint you know what i'm
saying
it's an entity i went i signed up i took
eight weeks worth of classes
you know for the holy spirit i went down
there i had to get a [__] name i had
to get a voucher
uncle to be my [__] spirit whatever i
did there and
i'm walking out of there no spirit and
there was nothing i was still a
miserable [__]
miserable i [__] hated coming home i
hated it i come home and [__] how are
you how was your day
uh what do you think about life what do
you want to go for vacation i don't
[__] know
i just got off a [__] roof okay i
just got off a roof with tar i got
sunburned in my [__] eyeballs
guys it was terrible was the first time
i was really sick depressed
i was doing an eight ball and two snorts
you understand me i was blowing an eight
ball and two [__] snorts
and i'm in the halfway house and i'm
[__] with them
i'm going through a psychological i'm
drinking [__] battery acid and
vinegar
and putting drano on my dick i'm doing
everything
to beat these [__] piss tests you
don't have a [__] idea when you're a
junkie
and they're pissing you three days a
week and you're [__] with these
[__]
i figured it out i was torturing i was
breaking machines on them
i was my dick look like i'm just
recovering it's ten years of putting
vitamin e on my dick
my dick looked like a vietnam vet he had
holes in it and [__]
bandages diddy mao diddy bow
[__]
so when it snows you can't
[__] uh you can't uh
do roofing
no you can't rule so you gotta take the
day off the kid would go to daycare till
like two and i would just sit there all
[__] day
mind [__] myself for two weeks you
know there was this video store one day
by mistake i rented punch line
with tom hanks and sally whatever feels
the flying nun
and i brought it home guys and right
there i'm like oh it's
a movie about stand-up comedy he wins a
contest and that's what i kept thinking
i'm like maybe i'll win a contest
and they'll put me in a [__] movie
you know and i'm like who the [__] am i
i'm not a funny guy just because some
convict said it just some [__]
convicts at it you know
so i uh watched the the movie and i was
caught i'm like i gotta get into
stand-up comedy
you know but i gotta pass it by my
[__] republican wife
and her [__] family and they're gonna
ask me about my felonies and
how would i consider this [__] and sure
enough one day i said you know what at
the dinner table or something i'm
thinking i'm getting into stand-up
comedy
it was like i fought it
i was like well you have a family and
how are you gonna do it and there's
drugs on those bars and you could never
do it
you know who gave you the idea you were
funny i mean they were just torturing me
guys and i'm sitting there going what
the [__]
you know this guy was a lieutenant
colonel but he never did nothing else in
his [__] life
and the mother was a housewife and
here's my [__] [__] ex-wife
sitting across from me
you know what the [__] did she do you
know i'm sitting there going i don't
even want to do this [__]
i don't want to [__] do this [__] you
know
so it took me you know i quit roofing i
said [__] it i'll sell
cars and at night i could try because
when you sell cars you can have
you know i contacted people and i went
to sell cars and i had seoul cars when i
was in college
and there was a guy that i did not get
along with at all
he hated me and i [__] hated him and
after the first month one day
as i was he was a manager as i was
leaving he called me over he said come
here for the and he goes
do you know what i did before i did this
job because i moved here because of my
wife my dad got sick and we're here with
him
he goes you know what i did for 12 years
i booked [__] entertainment
in vegas at some club he took me inside
and showed me his notebooks we had taken
pictures with and i'm like
you never say this [__] you just act
like a salesman he's like no you know
this is what i'm gonna do i can't live
in vegas no more he goes and i gotta
tell you something
he goes if i ever got into managing i
would [__] manage you
i'm like manage me for what he goes
calmly i'm telling you i can make some
money with you i'm like get the [__] out
of here he's like i'm telling you
so that was the first guy that really
pushed me then there was another guy a
manager that was a white [__]
dude that i'm gonna see this weekend as
a matter of fact
and he was so white he used to call me
over there and go joey
you want to keep selling cars all your
life he goes i'm thinking of leaving my
wife
i want to take you on the road because
just me and you in a [__] car
i swear to god and he go every day i
want you to you want to do stand-up
comedy he goes i want you to write on a
piece of paper
how are you going to get to your goal
every day how are you going to get
closer to that goal
i don't know what he was talking about
he would do with selling cars like he
put you want to sell 10 cars a week
right
or you got to take ups you got to make
phone calls you got to do this and he'd
make you plan your day i've never had
that before
and one day i'm walking in the back of
the dealership and his son was one of
the guys that watched the car like he
was 16
and he runs over to me he goes dog the
other day i heard my mom and dad arguing
and i heard my dad threaten her and said
he was just gonna quit his job
quit the marriage and take you on the
[__] road with him
and he's on facebook this kid we talk on
facebook now [__] 20 years later
and uh i went home and i'm like all
these people have this confidence in me
but these [__] people who are around
me don't
and then i went out and uh
i was roofing one day i was roofing for
my brother i was bringing him materials
and it was snowing or something he goes
can you bring your tools back it was the
weirdest [__] thing
like all right you know i had a day off
and i brought him the tools back
and i stopped to get breakfast and there
was a denver post
and guys there was a page that was
folded and when i opened it up
in the top of the page it said you know
stand-up comedy taking storm in denver
again roseanne had just hit
and they were developing all these
classes in denver for comedians and
there was one class with 33 [__]
dollars
and i took the number i ripped the
[__] thing on the newspaper and i
called down there and they're like yeah
you could start sunday at the
at the university of colorado i was
going to school anywhere it was 33
[__] dollars to be a stand-up comic
right i went down there i was ready to
be a [__] stand-up con i thought they
gave you like a microphone and [__]
right
i go down there it's three weeks and at
the end of three weeks the guy was from
long island it was really cool
and he talked to everybody he's like
this is what you need to do and
afterward he goes i want you to stay a
little later
he goes listen dawg i'm going to get
your job as a doorman and a club
because i really want you to work at
this at this time guys
i was still [__] selling cars i was
moving eight balls i was doing
everything i was
buying stolen cars and getting the vins
oh please don't get me [__] started
right
and i'm like what is this stand-up
comedy pain they're like nothing
this guy broke it down for me because
like first three years you're gonna
starve [__]
and i'm like you know what i'll do
comedy but i sell coke and i can balance
it out you know what i'm saying like
i could quit my job but i can still sell
coke and you know steal from kmart i can
still do my [__]
because i had a kmart that had defense
outside we used to rob that [__]
every day
lomo is the [__] ones you drive
[Laughter]
well i'm telling you this story i don't
want you guys to think that
this took me three days i thought about
doing stand-up for three [__] years
people
all right i'm the biggest [__] in the
[__] world i'm not gonna tell you
like most people call me like hey man
i'm thinking of doing stand-up i'm
writing material i'm like no you're not
you just procrastinate just get on stage
and get it over with
because for three years that's what i
would tell people i'm selling cars but
i'm standing up comedy what do you
perform in my kitchen
you know for my [__] dog i don't
perform i thought i was a stand-up comic
but you have to get out there
and again i kept [__] signing up for
the open mic and i would cancel every
week
and even after i had the doorman job the
club had stout at other clubs and they
would go all right we'll call over there
and tell them to put you up and every
week i would cancel every [__] week
i'd get a gram of coke do two lines and
i'd have to cancel
because i can't do coca oh yeah you
can't [__] do it you know what i'm
saying
so i would call up i got sick again you
know and i just kept pushing it back
guys and pushing it back like a [__]
[__] and finally one day i went down
there with my wife
she's like i'll help you go down there
she drove me we made a big thing of it
we went for dinner
i hated her by this time and she
basically hated me
okay we were two [__] ships in the
night she had her job
i had my job and that's it you know i i
worked from six to six
selling cars and i come home take a
shower and go [__] work the door
at a club until 10 o'clock at night i
didn't even see it we were both [__]
miserable you know
and she drove me down there and i got on
stage guys for the first time
and it was the weirdest thing because i
was i was walking off it came to me
i go i'm [__] done this is i got
higher than any drug i had ever done
heroin coke tuminols quaaludes
this was the [__] epitome of high i
couldn't even walk
to see her like i was like frankenstein
like the [__]
didn't even come out of my dick it had
just run up and down through my body
like that's what happened
that's the sense of come like the the
euphoria i got
and she knew when she looked in my eyes
right there she knew it was all over we
let i did
i got on stage june 18 to 91 by
september we were done
done that's it the baby was 18 months
old but she knew
and at that time i knew i'm like listen
i'm gonna do this part-time and whatever
and i just [__] around you know i
didn't take advantage of it i was doing
drugs i thought i was a playboy i was
slinging dick
i bought an acura i i didn't [__]
know
i'm not gonna lie to you i bought an
acura you know
and i was sitting there one night and i
see this ad in the paper for boulder i
live in boulder and they're like
comedy contests every [__] tuesday at
the broker the broker was this old place
that tuesday nights had state night
like prime rib for 14.95 you got a free
comedy ticket
so people basically went to eat the
steak they'd give a [__] about the
comedy
but they were losers so they sat there
and just sat there and watched you
so i went down to one of the comedy
contests one night and it was [__]
traumatizing the magician
the guy who opened up with a magician
and his birds would get stuck in the
lights and [__]
the rabbit wouldn't come out of the hat
he was [__] terrible
and i'm like you know what even in the
coked up haze i'm better than that
[__] guy
so i joined the contest and i kept
winning winning winning winning and i
ended up winning the whole [__] thing
i won the whole [__] thing with
nothing with six minutes of material
that i would write that morning
and i went to the management the
management came to me and they're like
dawg
you brought all these [__] people in
here but i was a real promoter i'm like
one of these promoters now they email
you oh my god
come to a vip i call you and say look a
dog i just picked up 100 valium
i'm saying i got some tens come on down
and there's a dude down there selling
blow it's one stop shopping
dog you got back come on down you got
blow down there we'll hook you up at the
bar
bro all my junky buddies were down here
bro where's the comedy show right
i had everybody down there right all the
invicts from the halfway house
everybody so i won because i brought the
most people you know what i'm saying
like i won then i went to them and i'm
like listen i bought all these people
let me host on tuesday nights and that
was my only job my job all week was just
to write jokes sell valiums
and do comedy on tuesday nights that was
my whole [__] career
and again i [__] around with it i
didn't take it seriously you know
and now i was going to war with my wife
and the kid was involved
and we were just going into this private
[__] war where
you know i had to beat the boyfriend up
and then he sent somebody to beat me up
and
it was one of those type of things and
and you know what
it was just too much so i said [__] it
i'm gonna give this a break
and i'm gonna go to new york and do
comedy and i went to new york for nine
months
you know how many times i got on stage
in nine months six times
i [__] did nothing i went to new york
and got high i lived with my buddy
george
and he was on heroin i was on coke i
used to call him the pin cushion cause
that's all he [__] did was shoot
heroin i swear to god you wake up on a
monday the room was filled with little
blood spots and [__]
it was [__] classic he was my dog
though i love that [__]
we talk every day even today i'm a
soldier he's off to h now though
he's a family man now he frames pictures
and [__] you know what i'm saying
but so something i don't know what it
was like i missed my daughter
and i had gone to the clubs in new york
and i had seen what it was like because
that's what i was doing i was just
watching
i wouldn't get on stage i was a
spectator at that point
and when i went back to colorado to try
to be a dad i said [__] i'll just do
comedy in colorado i'd be a good father
i'll get my life together and i went
back to colorado and it just got worse
between
me and the kid and the mother it just
kept getting worse and
i was no [__] angel either but
sometimes when you get in the divorce
sometimes it goes that way there's
nothing you can do to control it you
know
so i had nothing i didn't have my
daughter i lived in a rocky apartment
you ever see rocky won the [__]
apartment he had
i had the same thing the bathroom the
bathroom is the bedroom is the living
room is the dining area you know what
i'm saying
it's just one room and it all smells
like [__] you follow me
it was so bad i even have mice i didn't
have [__] mice like the mice are like
dog what the [__]
i lived there for a year and a half and
i never turned the stove on one [__]
time
i swear to god this apartment was my
comedy apartment because when i went
back something it inspired me to do
i was i had nothing all i had and i was
working as a bookie at the time of the
sports betting service
and i'm still [__] doing comedy i'm
still doing blow and i had the
i had a stand-up shower the the
apartment was this big
this was the kitchen the door i had a
little couch here
there was a weightlifting bench that
doubled as a dinner table
a weightlifting bench and also a hanger
and a coat hanger on the [__] things
right
i had a tv and an upside down box and i
had a little closet in the back that i
just put a bed in there there was no
furniture so all you did was
i took the door down all you did was
walk in the door and fall over
and just spin around and put the air
conditioner on like a doctor right
like a doctor no [__] walking around
no vacuuming and [__]
this was a rock in the bathroom i had a
hole in the wall where i threw all my
empty packages
from coke i get all coked up and i throw
it in there in case the cops came in i
didn't want
and one day i got so paranoid i took the
[__] wall down right and went in
there
there was a thousand empty things i was
licking all of them they had mold on
them
that's when you know it's time to move
when you take the wall down
you're like [__] it i took the wall down
to see what was in there
so i was starting to go on the road a
little bit i had friends that would get
me on the road my first stop was
michigan
first time ever i got in a car and drove
and i went to michigan
and the second night there i meet a
[__] crazy stripper
and she's like i'm moving to seattle a
week because my boyfriend wants to kill
me i go [__] it stop and get me in
boulder
i moved to [__] seattle and
opportunity had opened you know
i was about to kill my ex-wife or the
boyfriend or they were gonna kill me
and i seen it i knew it i know me they
were taking me into murky waters
where i didn't care i was prepared to
kill one of them and go write jokes with
jay leno on a computer
and fax them every day that's what was
in my heart i'm like when this goes down
i'm going to kill one of them
and i'm probably because i was going to
kill both of them but i was raised
without a mother
so i can't kill the mother but i was
going to kill the [__] boyfriend that
was my philosophy and i'm sorry if i'm
being too forward
go through a divorce sometimes you want
to kill somebody you follow me
you go through a divorce you want to
kill somebody in your heart no matter
how nice of a person you are there's
three or four days where you're like
today's the [__] day
that night when you go home you're like
whoo somebody else got killed today
you know you ever drive your car stone
you're driving the sun's in your eyes
and you see a guy on a bicycle you're
like i almost hit him
you don't know how lucky that
[__] is you want to pull over
and give him a hug dawg today's your
lucky day
i almost just killed you right i didn't
hear you i had my ipod on your lucky dog
because you weren't going to hear none
but that's it it was over
you know what i'm saying i don't know
what happened
in my heart these people didn't know how
close they came to dying
i used to pray every day and i said you
know what dog this is what i'm gonna do
i'm not doing nothing here it's gonna
end up bad i'm gonna embarrass myself in
front of my daughter which i already
have
let me do this let me go away let me try
to do something with my life
and i could come back proud
you know that was my philosophy i'll
never forget leaving boulder for my
first gig in idaho by myself i had a 600
car and i had two drivers license at the
time i had two colorado ones right
and i said [__] i got to save on money
because i had like 20 bucks to get to
idaho
i went to the gas station filled it up
and go dawg i left my cash at home and i
gained a spare
license that's old gangster type [__]
you know what i'm saying
because it was expired anyway it says
sit in a drawer [__] it you take it
right
they didn't the lady was arab she didn't
read through quite he's like [__]
take it all right [__] it
no offense i know that you know this is
20 years ago they didn't know how to
speak english at all then
they didn't know about the [__] date
they just got a job you know [__]
happens
the [__] people i told you i was
racially insensitive not racist i love
everybody
big [__] difference right so
i leave when i leave and you know i go
to seattle
and and i'm in seattle for 18 months but
from
i went from doing comedy 12 times a
month in denver to 20 times or 30 times
a month in seattle
and i was having fun i had to strip a
girl we're [__] we're beating each
other up i kept going to jail
and i was i'm telling you it started
with a jaywalking ticket and then
and ended up they threw me out of the
[__] state that's how it started with
a jaywalking ticket because i didn't pay
and they came to the rest of me
[__] seattle don't [__] with those
people those are republicans
[__] right there that's
that's mayberry with skyscrapers that's
what my friend used to call it right
so i'm in trouble up there but i'm
developing as a comic you know i'm
sleeping on floors
it makes you right i was living in an
apartment i had [__] out the window i
had no toilet in the
in the office it was an office building
i swear to god dawg
you got to do you got to be creative
when you're a comedian you got to cut
down on [__]
so instead of renting an apartment i
rented an office space they didn't have
a shower
they had a toilet but it was locked but
i had a window i just sit out there and
[__] out my window
[__] it you know what i'm saying i wipe
my ass draw the paper out there for the
pigeons [__] it
hey man that it was 125 a month dawg
so what i didn't have a bathroom you
piss out the window i bring water and
then the morning i go to the gym
i was in the best shape of my life
because i'm a clean [__] i was
in the gym three four times a day taking
a shower
they got the shaving cream in there you
put in your hair you know i'm saying
it was a nice white gym not like the
ymca they got no towels and [__]
there's one of those gyms they got their
own toothbrushes you grease your hair
back
you steal a comb for later
what the [__] is wrong with you people
when you're a comic you gotta [__]
that's the sacrifice you give listen a
lot of times
comedians don't like comedians i don't
like a bunch of [__] comedians
but i'll shake their hand because i know
the struggle they went through
if they sacrifice half the [__] i
sacrifice i sacrifice half my life don't
get me wrong
i snore the coke but i lived in the car
do you know what i'm saying
i knew where to cut down it's like cuban
jews when they came over they came over
in a raft with an
engine they knew where to cut the cost
do you follow me sometimes you just got
to cut costs a lot of you didn't get
that joke
[__] it i ain't going to say it again
you missed a good joke you know what i'm
saying but you're focused on the [__]
waiter that's what happens
you know what i'm saying so i lived in a
car but i was still [__]
snorting coke and eating pills i just
cut down on rent
so i was always sacrificing something
and the comics do the same
hey my first year on the road i ate more
subway veggie and cheese sandwiches
than [__] jared do you understand me
goes veggie and cheese cause they're
2.99 for a 12 inch those [__]
last all day
you cut that into fours when you're on
the road
that dry [__] bread with a mountain
dew that's [__] death right there
you know what happens to your stomach
after [__] five years of eating that
[__] so i understand the
the struggle so that's why i respect
them even though i'm like this guy's a
[__] [__]
i respect what i'm saying i respect that
he had to go somewhere along his life
you know we work on the [__] weekends
that means there's no weddings there's
no [__] play time with your family
you fly back on monday and i'm not
saying nothing bad about it i'm just
explaining that
there's cuts that you make like in any
[__] job if you're a plumber
you know you got to wear a [__] mask
cause you'll die from smelling [__]
there's always some cut back if you work
with asbestos you make 22
an hour but you're gonna get cancer
there's always something you know what
i'm saying
if you cut hair you cut hair on
commission there's always a by the
[__] way right or wrong there's
always something in your jaw
so i'm living in seattle i'm on
probation on top of probation
i'm going to anger management class but
i'm doing comedy every night
i'm making a little bit of money i'm
paying child support it's okay
everybody else is doing great around me
la seemed like a distant [__] fart
like i was doing comedy at that time six
years and i'm like i'm not i'm never
gonna be good enough for l.a
so i'm gonna just stay in seattle and
keep [__] the stripper and i'll die
up here whatever
one christmas eve i walk off like two
nights before christmas they just hire
locals because they'll be dead anyway
and some dude came up to me and he's
like dog i work for cbs
we're looking for a guy like you for a
pilot would you be willing to go to l.a
and shoot a pilot i'm like no i want to
stay and [__] in my [__] window
in the office you give me a hotel for
three days i'm good i don't even want
money you know what i'm saying just put
me in the hotel i want a [__] in the
toilet
it's been months you're following me a
nice warm toilet with toilet paper
i don't have to balance myself i would
read the paper
[Laughter]
so he says no no it's going to shoot for
like a month so i need you to move down
there
and we're gonna give you some money and
move you down there
i'm like you can't be [__] serious
so at that time i wasn't even allowed
out the state of seattle
and i told the guy yeah i'll be down in
la by the end of january i gave him my
word he goes we'll send you a check to
move
and we'll give you another check when
you get down there at this time i had
nothing in the bank
no credit cards no nothing nothing 10
would have been a lot of [__] money
to me and i'm supposed to leave on the
29th i got a letter like on the 8th of
january
that they wanted to revoke my probation
and throw me in [__] jail for 90 days
i'm like what the [__] am i gonna do
so i went to my attorney i showed the
paperwork from cbs he goes let's have an
emergency [__] meeting they took it
to court
the courtroom guy goes the judge goes
listen you seem like a nice guy he goes
i caught your act on new year's eve
he had seen me new year's eve right with
doug stanhope right so
he [__] loved it this is 1995 96 guys
uh he goes like you have different views
on the world because i'm going to let
you go to la but i don't want you to
come back to seattle for two years
until you get your life in the head
together so i moved to [__] la and i
came to la
and i got a little room and i took half
the money and bought a bunch of blow
and i went right to the comedy store and
guys i was out of my [__] league
in my heart i was always out of my
league i'm like
i'm just gonna go through and i gave
myself like a year i go i'll give a year
if nothing happens i'll move back to
colorado kill those [__]
and you know certify what i am a piece
of [__] certified [__] it what am i
going to do this [__] for
i'm going to be out here with all these
good looking people you know what i'm
saying
i'm not going to get none but at least
i'll know in my heart i always want to
know in my heart i gave it a [__] try
i can't see not giving anything a
[__] try you know you got to give it
a try [__] it
if they say no suck my dick you go home
and you go back to kmart you sell coke
until the heart ticks out [__] it
you lived your life but at least you
gave it a shot and i [__]
came here and i got right into it i went
right to the comedy store
why [__] around i had heard that she
that was the place richard pryor kenneth
why [__] around and that little woman
looked at me and she goes can you come
back next week and do five minutes
my [__] dick got hard again like all
the sperm was supposed to come out of
here
and it just went right to my feet and
jacked up to my ears that time it
dripped out
that time i had a couple drips to come i
smelt it i'm like well you on a monday
night look at this [__]
so it's amazing you know that the timing
is everything in life
you know people say timing is everything
no you have a window
in life the window opens up and you
either [__] tackle that [__]
or you close the [__] window
and that's all i did at that time i i
just kept throwing spaghetti against the
wall and i would go to managers and they
go you're too old
you're too ugly you're too fat dog i
heard a bunch of [__] right
and then we shot the pilot and the pilot
didn't get picked up on cbs nothing
and then there's one guy seeing me at
the store and he's like hey i want to
sign you like all right let's do it he
signs me and he goes i'm gonna
i can't make money off you as a comic so
i'm gonna send you in for auditions
i'm like all right send me in for
auditions right so the first audition
they sent me for was like churches
chicken and all this [__]
commercials you never forget this stuff
right like the guy that got him in the
face with the snowball you never forget
that [__]
so i i kept going in for commercials
commercials commercials i'm like what am
i going to go in for a big feature
motion picture you know
and finally when they call me in for
taco bell one day
and it's the first commercial with the
dog
and there was a miami commercial with a
cuban cab driving they hired me to be
the cuban cab driver
i got a [__] commercial holy [__] i
could stay an extra eight six months now
because i did something you know on the
back of my head i'm like hoof i just
bought myself six months [__]
[__] the snow you know i didn't care
about the money you don't care about
nothing it's just
that you move forward and i get to the
commercial shooting they're like dog we
wrote off your commercial
but we want you to sit here for three
days and get paid i don't give a [__] i
get paid for three days
i just brought like a book or something
like the second day the guy heard me
talking
and he goes dog i need to for you to do
in this commercial and he put me in
there
and i made the [__] commercial and at
least i had something to work with now
so the guy started sending me in for
different tv shows
and i was [__] my [__] pants guys
and then he sent me in for a movie
called basketball
he sent me in right but the truth was
listen to this guys again
he sent me in for nypd blue
but it was nine pages and i didn't know
i didn't [__] read this so i go in
the room i'm like yeah how you doing
thank you mr diaz that was fantastic
you'll hear from our people get the [__]
out of here
[__] fat [__] trying to be and i'm
walking down the hallway
sweating because they send you to the
other side of fox i'm walking
and i had a shirt with a string on it
life is [__] up
dog and there's a door right here as i
get to right here a lady cuts me off
and she goes are you here for the
audition
i guess so she goes sign your name read
this sheet of paper
it was only one sheet one line i could
read this [__]
i start reading this [__] oh my god i
can read this [__] dawg
i can read this [__] i go in
there i read it she goes read it again i
read it again read it again and read it
again
she was thank you very much for coming
in i leave i'm living on schrader in
hollywood in a [__] hotel where crack
hoes live
and i could afford a nicer hotel but
[__] that i want action you know what
i'm saying
[__] what would you rather have a pool
or would you rather have the option of
going to your hotel lobby
and getting your dick sucked by a hooker
with a missing finger you know what i'm
saying
for five hours on the way home you
follow me
i [__] i had great times and now it's
a hostile it's a hostile now european
people
every time i walk by that i'm like
i hope you're not in room 113 smell the
[__] sheets you little filthy [__]
animals
and it was one of those hotels that had
a pay phone in the hallway and they
would say who's joey
who's joey and i'm in my room one day
stone whacking off
the people next door are [__] in the
afternoon i'm over there
joey i'm like joey that's me and i
opened the door i'm like i'm joey like
the [__] phone guy where
you been i go downstairs hello that's my
manager and he's like hey dog
you're sitting down i'm like yeah what's
up he's like you're in the movie
basketball
they're gonna pay you 5 500 for four
weeks
for one [__] line right i'm like
no come on
yeah and i was a criminal like a
[__]
i made them pay for my sag but here's
what gets better that movie everybody
had roller skates right
i would go on every day and have a new
set of roller skates with the receipt i
take the roller skates home with me
every night
i'm a criminal dog i'd stop at that
scottish warehouse what's the name where
they sell skis and [__] every day come
in the
sports authority how you doing my
grandmother got me these for christmas
what do you think
they had a truck full of them do you
understand me a truck
a trailer truck and every day they put a
pair in my room and every day i'd steal
them and go back to this
dog where's my boots we gave you a pair
yesterday we're all out of 13s give me a
12. it don't matter
give me eleven i'll take a kid size i
don't give a [__]
it's all 139 across the board you know
what i'm saying
bro i must have robbed them for 80 pair
[__] boots dog
that's how much of a [__] criminal i
was i didn't give a [__]
i was going in there for a month coked
out every morning
6-0 i just go in there look at jenny
mccarthy and lay in the trailer and
sleep huh
and the one night i drank red wine you
know red wine [__] you up i get in
there like
you're shooting today i had never done
anything guys
cut oh nothing i get out there i don't
even know what i'm doing like where's
your roller skates there ain't no left
if you watch basketball i [__] i [__]
make believe i got scared
that's how tight my acting was in those
days fresh out the box [__] that acting
class [__]
like where's your skates i don't i don't
have none doug where is case there's no
more size 13
12 11 10 we got nothing
if you watch that movie and i turn away
i'm on [__] my sneakers though
what [__] you
but i was getting acting roles but my
stand-up was getting beat up people
[__] hated me
they hated me i was too dirty this but
the comedy store like me and mitzi sure
liked me
and that's all that [__] mattered to
me that's all that mattered to me
then a movie called analyze this came
out and i went to see the [__] movie
in the movie theater i had the tears
coming down my face
because i kept saying i could do this
[__] movie i could [__] do this
and six months later i got an audition
for a movie
some big ass movie and i go in there and
i read the legos listen
i can't use you for this but i could use
you for my next movie analyze that
and i go what and she go send me some
reviews right before christmas she go
send me some real
and i had done this movie called the
mezzos about gay people give a gay mafia
and i was a gay mobster right it was
[__] great it's still on i start on
the gay channel late night sometimes
they play it on
i don't tweet it because [__] it i don't
want nobody to see it they might get
their own
they might not tweet me back with
pictures of their dick and [__] you know
what i'm saying
so i'm just telling you guys because you
came tyler wednesday night i love you
[__]
you know you think i'm special i think
you're special so now we're all special
you guys know secrets and [__] don't
don't look it up and don't tell nobody
cause i kill you i hunt you down and
[__] out your [__] window you know
what i'm saying
so i brought the [__] tape tool and i
sent it to new york
and everything was a roadblock dog they
called me to audition i had to go to new
york i had ten dollars in the bank
i had to get my buddy give me a buddy
pass guess what they lost my [__]
luggage
so i had to go to new york to two and
then my audition was at five i had to go
buy a warm-up suit and show oh it was a
[__] nightmare
and i went in there and nailed it but i
didn't want to nail it guys
i didn't want to nail that movie for the
movie i wanted to nail that movie
because it was harold ramus
do you understand who ronald reimus is
ghostbusters caddyshack
uh animal house [__]
uh this best movie is groundhog day i
mean this
[__] is a tank and you know why
because
when he worked on c-tv they hired all
his friends for sat night live
but they didn't hire him they didn't
think he was good enough and this
[__] took a pen and he goes
really
i'm gonna sink your [__] boat and he
wrote [__] uh the first
bill murray won and i remember sitting
on the set
again sperm coming out of every orifice
at that time
i get emotional thinking about it this
is harold ramis so it didn't matter if
anybody didn't like me and stand up
it didn't matter if they liked me at the
comedy store it didn't matter whether
they liked me or not
i was working next to a god and the guy
hired me he's seen my tape
and he took the time to talk to me after
i met that guy my attitude changed
completely i was like
[__] these because he told me that day
he goes didn't even invite me to
montreal
[__] those [__] he goes you
know in other words like they can't do
nothing that castro hasn't already done
go for it bro
go for it [__] him he goes when you see
a movie send tapes
send it right to the director i'm
looking at this [__] like this
is harold ramus
talking to me a piece of [__] again
another guy that if he knew i was
lighting hook his wigs on fire he
wouldn't be talking to me like that you
know what i'm saying
he took the time to talk to me right
there i was like wait a second
this guy is a [__] street guy this
guy's a badass [__] with a
i'd like to say he's a badass jew i'm
not sure and i don't want to offend
nobody
it's yom kippur you know what i'm saying
i want to keep it safe i don't want the
jew gods pissed off at me i fall down
then i can't get an attorney you know
that goes
you [__] to the jews on john kapoor
that's what you get now you can't get an
attorney
you got to go to court with some african
dude with a wig and [__]
i'm saying i need this [__] in my life
i'm definitely doing [__] 20.
but that guy [__] told me to have
balls he goes [__] him if they don't
like you
[__] him in the ass then come on them
and [__] him in the ass again like that
type of attitude
this is a guy from chicago i was like
god damn i've been missing the [__]
boat
so i went home you know and i started
working harder and i'm still doing coke
i'm not a criminal no more
i'm still selling a little bit of coke
on the side if you know what i mean i'm
doing movies i'm trying
i'm doing stand-up and then something
happened that really [__] me up
i sent an envelope in for a movie
because it was
it was the winter time and i figured
they're not going to be open i sent the
movie
and they called me back and it was
spider-man 2. right so i go in there
and it's all these movie stars in there
and they go put you and i went with a
yankee head on and [__]
and i got that [__] movie and that's
another guy that i admired since i was a
guy you know
uh the one movie he made the horror guy
uh sam
sam raimi that [__] is a genius
and i get to meet him and he's talking
to me and [__] this motherfucker's
talking to me like dog
i like your audition tape you and i'm
like what the [__] is this [__]
why are these people talking to me
and then i became friends with this
little girl on the set i would stick up
for her and one day i'm at the thing
stealing pomegranate juice because
pomegranate juice was big then
i would go there and take one for me for
later oh spider-man 2 was great because
they gave me my own little room in the
back
and i'd smoke dope in the [__] room
then i leave and i go get how
sam raymond i go sam can i talk to you
somebody keeps breaking into my room and
smoking marijuana
he would go tell me what are you telling
me for i don't know what to tell you and
i would go in there
and smoke dope and [__] right so
spider-man was great guys
but so i became friends with a little
girl and she was like a little you know
she was kind of
she was a hollywood girl dog you know
can you imagine being raising your dad's
like a big shot
but i didn't know her dad was a big shot
nobody had said nothing one day i was
drinking pomegranate juice
and this dude comes over to me he's like
so you joey i'm like
it was my little girl my wife talked
about you all weekend what's the deal
you're a pervert or something
right like i'm like nah we're all on the
[__] train together
you know you're on the train you got to
talk to somebody you know and she's
talking about she was insulting actors
she was calling them ba which is short
for bad actors right this girl was
[__] hilarious she's like he's a bad
actor
he's a bad actor you're okay he's a bad
i'm like this little girl got balls if i
had a daughter i want her to be her you
know so
i meet the father and i forget what his
[__] name is he won an oscar for star
wars for
cinematography or something he was
working on the he won some for
spider-man too
too who's the baseball player that went
crazy from philadelphia
nails dijkstra so this is dijkstra the
guy's name was something dijkstra was
like a second cousin
and this is where the story comes from
right that we're in the thing
and he smells me and he goes dog you
holding
i go yeah i'm holding him let's go for a
walk
it's about 7 15 in the morning right so
i go huh i go if you want we go to the
[__] apartment don't worry i'll go
tell raimi that somebody broke in again
and smoked pot my thing
he's like i heard about that what the
[__] because the whole bottom floor
would stink at [__] sony
right so we walk around the back and
there's these poles and lights and [__]
we're back there
and i take out like this one hitter and
we're back there smoking and all sudden
you hear a bunch of [__] moving right
[Music]
and someone like a.d comes out and she's
like excuse me
they're looking for you on the set not
me the guy now wait a second
if i won an oscar in this town for star
wars
i'd be walking around my dick out all
day
i'd be a dairy queen how you doing yeah
let me get two [__] whoppers whatever
you got
somebody's sucking my dick at burger
king
so for this lady that's an a.d to talk
to him like this i was blowing the [__]
away you know me dog i'm crazy
and he's like well they're looking for
you don't you have your walkie-talkie
and he's got the [__] one hitter
and he's like no
and he gives it back to me and all of a
sudden she goes well anyway they're
looking for you and she goes like this
and she turns back and she goes are you
two guys smoking marijuana
do you know it's 7 15 in the morning
so he don't say nothing because he's too
[__] high
and then she put what's wrong with you
that's just it's 7 15 in the morning i'm
like
7 15 in the morning what's wrong with me
what's wrong with you
if you ain't high go [__] yourself right
and that's where that started from
that's what it's over right
so here i am i'm causing drama on
spider-man 2.
it's bad enough i got one line they kept
me for a month i'm in there all day and
[__] i'm in there at seven how you doing
on fridays they had lots of tales all
these people eating salads
why are you eating salad there's lobster
tails i was eating i was eating lobster
tails like they were [__]
little [__] pieces of chicken you
should have seen me
another one joey yeah nobody else is
[__] eating them what are you gonna
take them to go
then i get a [__] call one day right
now through all this [__] i'm on blow
guys
you know i got a great girlfriend who's
not my wife and she's pregnant
at that time she didn't know what the
[__] was going on she knew but
i'm on blow and i'm going on these
auditions and
i didn't know what my next step was you
know one movie i got that i didn't think
that really helped me also was rodney
dangerfield put me in one of his last
movies
and just being around that guy like
nobody i didn't even have a [__]
agent guys nobody would talk to me i
didn't go to montreal
i didn't do nothing for tv nobody would
talk to me it's like [__] i always
had a cold
but here's rodney dangerfield talking to
me they hired me they didn't even have a
character for me
they just would make me come in every
day and they give gave me a name and
they would ask rodney ronnie what are
you going to do with joey
i don't know time to come in we'll find
something for them and i would sit there
all day and they'd put me a scene so
here's all these [__] people that
liked me
but nobody around me would give me love
so
you know by that time my confidence is
getting a little higher i'm like [__]
these [__] i'm just going to go
for it
and my agent calls me one day goes i
sent you a breakdown
and it's for a movie called the longest
yard did you ever watch the original i'm
like [__] yeah
and he goes they're looking for a guy
just like you so i go call up let's get
this going
he calls me back goes joey they want a
star
i go wait a second look read this
[__] thing
so time went on and i started snooping
around when i had done spider-man i met
this
dude on the set so he worked for the
sandler people so i called him up and
he's like joey i was just thinking about
you
because your name came up the other day
he was there looking at tony siragusa
and big [__] but somebody's and
somebody suggested you right
and i'm like [__] it all right so he
goes but they really want to give it to
sarah goosa
and if not they really want to give it
the big [__] from the sopranos right
and i go all right [__] it dawg i'll
work this out
guys i was in houston texas one night
coked up to the [__] gills
five in the morning trying to whack off
looking out a window
figuring out whether i should call a
chick or something you know what i'm
saying just in horrible shape
and i was heartbroken about this movie
because in my mind i knew this movie
would give me a boost
and i'm heartbroken about this because
this is [__] me the next night i go
to the comedy club
and i tell this kid i go dog you have a
camera i go tomorrow
let's go over and shoot some things at
the university of houston
so i went to sports not authority but
played against sports and i bought the
smallest tightest [__] shirt they had
i bought the smallest [__] shoulder
pads and i bought a [__] kids helmet
and tight football pants with my balls
hanging out with my stomach hanging on
my [__] nut sack
the next day he goes what do you want to
do i'm trying to get in this longest
shot he goes you just told me all night
that they either want to give it to
sharipa
or or uh sarah goosa or big puss they go
you know what bro
all those guys are great comedic actors
but as far as funny
i've done half time at buffalo hockey
game
that to me guys is worse than getting
gang raped you understand me
if ten guys put a dick in my ass i'd
take that if i ever had to do buffalo
again
people throw hot dogs at you there ain't
no love during hockey or a buffalo game
dog
it's cloudy there there's more suicides
in buffalo anywhere else in the [__]
world do you understand me
i love the place i love buffalo new york
but dawg that was when i realized
how hard it was to really be a comic i
had the time in buffalo at a half time
of a [__] hockey game
okay and that was i said it i said i do
that i follow paul mooney every night
i gotta follow joe rogan at the [__]
comedy store if that doesn't mean
something that's gotta mean something
you know what it is to follow paul
mooney or dahmer
every [__] night guys think about
going to court when you're gonna go to
jail
and you know you're gonna go to jail
driving down to the comedy store
knowing you're going to be [__]
embarrassed in front of 60 [__]
people every night
well that's what i did and i said [__]
it if i did that
i could do this so i ran around and put
the [__] thing on tape
i called my agent i said dog i made a
tape he goes joey they've already made
tony sorry goose an offer
like a dog send this [__] tape send
it
and i called my boy and he gave me the
address to send and he sent it
and two days later [__] they called
me and they took me out the [__]
lunch
and guess what guys i had fought out i
didn't even have enough money to pay for
the valet parking
i had to park eight miles away and run
there and it was july i was sweating
[__] profusely
i had stayed up till six in the morning
doing blow plus the sweat from running
i was a [__] mess i had yellow
armpits you follow them saying to your
[__]
i remember ordering lunch and saying i
hope these [__] don't make me
pay
because i'm gonna be [__] embarrassed
i don't even have money for [__]
lunch guys
so this is all this [__] that's happened
and i'm sitting there in the longest
y'all i'd sat and i'm saying to myself
this was a hobby for me i was a [__]
criminal
this was a hobby i'm telling you guys
this was a hobby for me at first
through the [__] love of god and and
somehow i ended up in los angeles
and today i'm not successful and i'm not
david letterman and i'm not [__] cat
williams
but you know even though i don't talk to
my daughter
i did something with my life that i
thought i would
never guys please i thought i was a
piece of [__] and i still am i wake up
in the morning
i look in the mirror i gotta smoke a
joint just to come down from the [__]
heart attack you follow him saint
because i can't believe it that i'm
[__] gonna be 50. i can't [__]
believe but this all started as a
[__] hobby
this is a hobby that saved me i didn't
do good
i'm here with you [__]
so wednesday night if i was doing good
i'd be at home with six [__] asian
chicks lighting their [__] hairs on
fire
watching blue bloods or sons of anarchy
rubbing my toes you follow him saying to
you
i'm happy you guys came out thank you
very much for coming out tonight guys
thank you
for hearing it out and [__] you bad
[__]
you